my name is Matt Steiner I'm a senior
crime scene analyst I'm here today to
answer your questions from Twitter this
is forensic support
[Music]
SNM 79 asks Erp crime scene photo dot
dot dot
why did they draw a chalk around the
body so this was an old school method
that they used to use to identify where
a body was within a crime scene later on
Investigation after bodies removed you
could see where that body was in its
position we no longer do this because of
DNA contamination and trace evidence so
instead of shock now we just take
detailed photographs we'll document that
scene with laser scanner that laser
scanner is recording millions of points
per second as it's spinning and also
taking Imaging as it's turning we have
that scene preserved virtually we go
back and look at the 3D model we could
use Virtual Reality or augmented reality
to go back and walk through that scene
virtually now if we want to forensic
field asks question one of the most
popular methods for searching a crime
scene the three most common ones are a
line search a grid search and a Zone
search though there are many others a
line search it would be a line of
investigators and it would search a
crime scene in One Direction we search
in One Direction we don't find anything
we can then turn that search at 90
degrees and search in another Direction
and that's what's called a grid search
looking at it at an opposite angle at 90
degrees sometimes you'll visualize that
evidence the last most common search is
a Zone search when you take a crime
scene you break it down into smaller
parts as we discover evidence we'll go
around and we'll mark this evidence and
then we'll take additional photographs
showing that scene with the numbers and
then close-up views of evidence so some
markers will have a scale on it to show
this the size of it we need to do is
have a very systematic and methodical
order that you pick to search these
scenes doing things at random mailing
about is not acceptable josephb 977 asks
how many people got away with murder
before forensic science improved and DNA
it's a good question I think another
good question would be how many people
were wrongfully convicted before
forensic science science is constantly
improving and our goal is the truth and
we just want our investigation to show
that years ago a guy goes out to his car
a bag of trash next to his door and he
does what a lot of people would do is
just kicks the bag unbeknown saying and
there was a pipe bomb in that bag and it
detonated this is back in 2002 and we
had no answers 2006
I pulled some of this evidence from
storage and I re-swabbed the wiring and
the cap and the threading to the pipe
bomb and send that off for analysis
because in those short four years DNA
has advanced we identified this person
inside of his car he had more pipe bombs
and automatic weapons so sometimes the
work that we do not only can solve
crimes but it could also save lives siba
J Parker asks how do forensics determine
from blood spatter are there experiments
where you crack open dead bodies with
different weapons under different
circumstances first off it's not blood
splatter it's blood spatter blood isn't
always red it could be different colors
and tones blood from your arteries would
be bright red where the blood from your
veins would be a darker color as that
blood dries it gets oxidized it's
contaminated by the crime scene it can
also change its color and tone if we
have a suspect staying and we don't know
what it is oftentimes we'll do what's
called a presumptive test like we have
here this is an obti test will tell you
whether that's sample Could Be Blood you
still have to sample it you would send
it to a laboratory and they would say
what it is and sometimes to whom it
belongs to cadavers though to your
question generally are not used for
bloodstain pattern analysis but they are
used at some universities and they put
bodies in different circumstances so the
way they put the body in a car they'll
put it outside in the open in a field
different environments to see how those
bodies decompose over time lrcf asks how
did one of the most infamous unsolved
crimes committed on Valentine's Day in
1929 lead to new forensic science
techniques and ballistics and a reform
in gun control what they're referring to
is the Valentine's Day Massacre in
Chicago in 1929. seven Irish Mobsters
were lined up against the wall and they
were shot to death the weapons of choice
in this crime was the Thompson
submachine gun or Tommy gun back then
anyone could walk into a store and
purchase one of these weapons and
because of the public outcry of this
case we got our first federal gun
control law which took these weapons out
of the private actor's hand also with
this case was one of the first uses of
forensic ballistic evidence forensic
ballistics is the study of not only
Firearms but projectiles and casings
related to a firearm and able to
identify certain bullets or casings to a
known firearm Scotland Yard CSI asks how
do we identify human remains well it
depends on the state of the remains
privacy investigators work with a
medical examiner's office or a coroner's
office to determine whether it remains
are human or not human or meetings that
are in an advanced state of
decomposition to the point where they're
skeletal generally you want to work with
an anthropologist they could tell you
not only whether it's human or non-human
but what part of the body it came from
possibly the age or the sex of the
person by looking at different bone
growth markers and then sometimes
looking at the damage these bones could
determine the cause and manner of death
cxxiv001 asks are we sure that every
fingerprint is unique how is it possible
did you check every single one no it's
not possible to check every single one I
didn't check every single one they look
at verses a category they're looking at
whether it's a loop it's a whirl it's an
arch but then really what they're using
to identify is the minutia in your
fingerprints anytime you look at your
fingerprint that friction Ridge split it
comes together it starts it stops it
ends creates an island these are all
points of identification they're going
to look at in the hundred plus years of
analyzing and pairing fingerprints
they've yet to find two fingerprints
that are identical gov NG asks no
seriously does anyone know how to do a
drug as fold sure I could show you that
now a drug is fold or a pharmacy fold is
a way to preserve small amounts of trace
evidence in paper the first thing you
want to do with your paper you want to
fold it into thirds fold it a third of
the way in on both sides
then you want to fold it into thirds
again
and then what you wind up if you open
this up is you have
nine equal sized boxes you would then
collect your trace DNA and you put that
trace DNA into the center square and
then very carefully you want to close
that up make a little point on one end
take this point secure it into the
pocket on the other end and that you
have this little bindle now then what
you do is you would seal up this one end
put your signature across at the date
and then this would be over packed into
an Evidence envelope from chumi TM if
DNA could travel anywhere without us
even being there how reliable is DNA and
forensics after all DNA analysis gets
more sensitive as time moves on
technology gets better it gets more
sensitive there's different types of
crime scene contamination and there's
different types of DNA transfer intra
crime scene contamination happens within
the crime scene so if I touch this one
object I touch another object I'm
contaminating two different objects
within the same scene inter-crime scene
contamination is contamination between
two unrelated scenes I'm at a crime
scene I'm standing in blood that blood
is now drying on the soles of my shoes I
go to another unrelated crime scene now
that dry blood is starting to flake off
into that crime scene that's inter-crime
scene contamination there's different
types of DNA transference events that
can happen we have primary if I'm not
wearing gloves and I touch a door handle
I'm transferring my skin cells to that
door handle secondary contamination
would be if you and I shake hands and
now I touch that door handle and I
transfer your skin cells onto that door
handle when they analyze the DNA they
could tell the difference between a
major contributor and a minor
contributor analyst is not saying you
shot that person they're just saying
that there's a presence of your DNA on
that weapon Babyface 16 asks how in the
[ __ ] did O.J Simpson get acquitted
literally makes no sense the death of
Nicole Brown Simpson and Ron Goldman
it's a road map of what not to do at a
crime scene first off there's tons of
miscommunication mismatching with the
case investigators first went to OJ's
estate before going to the crime scene
so you have this inter-crime scene
contamination when they arrive they're
told about a bloody patent fingerprint
on a gate so that's a fingerprint and
pressed in Blood on the gate it's
probably one of the strongest types of
evidence you can get inside of a crime
scene that fingerprint was never
documented and never collected and by
the time they realized it and went back
to the scene that evidence was gone it
was cleaned up Nicole Brown she's out
outside and to cover her body from the
public view they went inside and they
grabbed a blanket from the home and it
covered her with it you want to use a
clean sheet to do that not something
from someone's home that already has who
knows DNA on it that can be transferred
to the body no one knew about DNA but
since then everyone knows the importance
of DNA with crime scenes so the
investigators no Faults of their own
didn't have these protocols in place and
now most departments do because of this
case I think if that crime scene
happened today and if OJ really did it
maybe we'd have a different outcome
today vigilante drones asks how are
drones helping with crime scene
investigation and accident
reconstruction it used to be if you
wanted to get these overhead views of
your crime scene you needed a helicopter
they're expensive they're not going to
show up to every crime scene and there's
restrictions on how close they can get
that scene now we can get a drone that's
inexpensive easy to use and put that
right above the scene to get our imagery
and there's a lot of other amazing
things we could do with drones today we
could pair this technology with laser
scanning and photogrammetry to get
three-dimensional models of our crime
scene from the air we're gonna put an
infrared camera on our drone to search
our crime scene someone might be buried
in a certain area the soil and the grave
is going to be looser so that soil is
going to heat up and cool down at a
different rate and we'll be able to see
that with the Drone with infrared Aidan
Kahana asks big question what's the
relationship between Sherlock Holmes and
the development of forensic science
Sherlock Holmes was a fictional
character
created by Arthur Conan Doyle used his
Keen powers of observation along with
inductive reasoning deductive reasoning
the scientific method applied to
criminal investigations inspired other
famous
forensic scientists notably Dr Edmund Lo
cart the father of forensic science
created the first forensic laboratory in
Lyon France Edmond la carte believed
that anytime someone is at a crime scene
something is transferred something is
Left Behind and something is taken and
this is lecard's principle of exchange
EP security mag digital forensics how
does it work and why is it significant
today digital forensics deals with the
documentation collection processing and
Analysis of data on digital devices it's
important because it shows up on every
case today you walk outside to get a cup
of coffee how many surveillance cameras
did you pass we don't walk outside
without bringing our cell phone with us
that's tracking us everywhere we go and
if you drive somewhere how many
surveillance cameras did you pass how
many traffic cameras did you pass how
many electronic plate readers did you
pass embedded technology and things that
surround us started with TVs but now
it's in refrigerators stoves and our
thermostats all this data could be used
for an investigation unfold Labs asks
how can AI help in solving unsolved
crimes if you have a crime scene and you
have all this surveillance footage that
you've got to look at this could take
hundreds or even thousands of hours you
could take AI along with computer vision
deep learning and object recognition and
train that program to look for certain
objects that's part of the crime and it
would take hundreds of hours to
thousands of hours can now be done in a
fraction of time AI is also used in
other technology one example is the
technology that we use for detection of
gunshots this software and technology is
called shot spotter shot spotter is a
series of acoustic sensors that are set
up in different areas that detect and
pinpoint gunshots this technology uses
AI to train itself to differentiate
between gunshots and other loud noises
viewpoints radio asks what did detectors
rely on to solve a case before forensic
science is part of the toolbox
investigators before doing science-based
investigations use testimony evidence
interviewing victims interviewing
Witnesses interrogating suspects and
investigating Alibis forensic science is
objective and testimonial evidence is
subjective our eyewitnesses sometimes
see something that's not there or miss
something that was there are suspects
that are interrogated they could lie and
even suspects will sometimes admit to
crimes that didn't even commit and again
your Witnesses may be wrong your
suspects May lie to you but your
evidence is not going to lie women in
forensic asks how can a communication
gap improve between lawyers and forensic
science experts as a forensic scientist
you have to explain very detailed
complex scientific ideas to people who
don't have the same education training
experience that you do for any case no
matter how experienced you are you
always want to prep with whoever's
calling you to testify you want to go
over questions that they might ask the
work that you did any sort of Errors you
might have made you want to have that
get that out in the open right away also
explain any sort of limits to the
analysis that you did eventually when
you get to court your testimony should
be simple enough that the jury
understands it it worked with the
investigator once that was testifying
and he kept saying that he was using an
ocular enhancement device eventually the
defense attorney asked what's a ocular
enhancement device and he said oh a
magnifying glass don't use big language
talk in simple terms toolkit misobi but
how does forensic science solve murders
that happened 50 years ago just because
the case is old doesn't mean that we
can't solve it that event is still
exists it still could be analyzed maybe
back then 50 years ago we only processed
that evidence with conventional
fingerprint powder but now we could pull
that evidence from Storage we could do
DNA analysis on it we could do chemical
development of fingerprints and we could
use a scanning electron microscope to
look at that evidence at Atomic level to
look at micro traces of DNA every day in
the news we see cold cases old cases
being solved with new technology and
advancements in forensic science a good
example of this would be the Golden
State killer case he had a series of
unsolved homicides and rape that was
eventually solved with new technology
that is forensic genetic genealogy we're
able to find out who a relative was of
this Kerala and from there their
investigation was this old-fashioned
gumshoe work they identified the suspect
who at one time was a police officer and
eventually they wound up with a tissue
that had his DNA that matched all these
different crime scenes Alicia love asks
how are the bodies in the dead marshes
so well preserved so what Lisa is
referring to is peat moss Boggs in
northern Europe where they have found
these bodies that are preserved for
thousands of years and some of them are
really amazing condition normally when
you die there's a process that happens
whatever the surrounding temperature is
your body temperature will match that
and that's called algor mortis also
because your blood is no longer
circulating your blood system gravity is
going to pull it down and then what we
see is it's called liver mortis or
lividity also because the chemical
changes in your muscles they were
temporarily stiffen and this is called
rigor mortis besides the process these
processes we have autolysis the
destruction of cells after they die
you'll see things like skin slippage
your skin will darken and your cells
will continue to break down liquefy to
the point so after a period of time
you'll become a skeleton so in northern
Europe these peat moss bogs are actually
a perfect environment to preserve a body
they have very little oxygen and they're
very acidic bacteria in these
environments can't grow and the body
winds up being pickled years ago I was
involved in a case a woman recalled her
stepfather bearing a body in her
backyard 40 years later we go to that
backyard we dig up the exact location
where he said the body was buried and we
find in a plastic garbage bag this body
and the body was really well preserved
it still had its flesh on it after 40
years so sometimes you just get that
right amount of bacteria or no bacteria
inside of an environment and that body
becomes preserved re the bile Jammer is
there money in forensics asking for a
friend if you're getting to forensics
for the money I would suggest pick a
different career it's not because you'll
be poor it's just that it's hard work
it's difficult job to do you got to
spend hours looking at the same piece of
evidence looking at the same crime scene
you're going to really love the work
otherwise you know years of looking at
this evidence or looking at these crime
scenes it's going to feel like a prison
sentence well that's it that's all the
questions I hope you learned something
until next time